Трикімнатна квартира в панельній багатоповерхівці
на київській Троєщині.
- Воля, легкість. Здаються всі кімнати великими і світлими,
тому що весь час тримали в маленькій і темній.
Практично без вікон і з ґратами.
За останні 5 років Надія Савченко
змінила 8 місць тримання під вартою чи ув'язнення.
П'ять - в Росії і три - в Україні. Різниця в тому, що
з російської в'язниці на неї чекали цілою країною
як на героїню. З українського ж СІЗО
чекали здебільшого родичі та друзі.
- Коли я першого разу повернулася з Росії, сусіди сказали:
"Ми думали, ви нам будинок відремонтуєте".
Цього разу, Слава Богу, вони цього вже не говорять.
Якось заспокоїлися.
О 6 ранку Надія Савченко вже зібралася на роботу.
У парламенті народна депутатка не була вже рік.
Савченко знає, що більшість її колег, які
рік тому проголосували за зняття з неї недоторканності
й дали згоду на арешт, не раді знову бачити її в Верховній Раді.
- У мене немає такого почуття, як помста.
Я вважаю, що це недоречно і не свідомо.
Я не хочу, щоб справа була просто закрита.
Це неправильно. Справа повинна бути доведена в судах до судах присяжних
і вона повинна бути доведена до логічного закінчення
в європейському просторі.
У березні 2018 року за притягнення Савченко
до відповідальності проголосував 291 парламентар.
Тоді Генеральна прокуратура звинуватила Надію Савченко
у плануванні державного заколоту та теракту
в центрі столиці. Для багатьох колег Савченко
вирішальними стали відео- та аудіодокази, які
продемонструвала Генпрокуратура. Багато депутатів
залишилися при своїй думці і нині,
коли Надію Савченко випустили з-під варти.
- Ми чули всі докази і сама Надія, в принципі,
ні від чого не відмовлялася.
- Я маю запитання до державної інституції процесуальної -
це генеральна прокуратура.
Якщо
те, що вони принесли, є фейком,
і вони
знущалися над людиною - це катастрофа.
Якщо це не фейк, а неспроможність
довести факти, це також катастрофа.
- З самого початку, коли побачили цей фільм,
зрозуміло було, що їх просто
спровокували на ці дії і підставили.
Надію Савченко не дивує, що Броварський районний суд
не продовжив арешт після спливу терміну
запобіжного заходу.
- Упустили з моменту. Боролися між собою. Було не до Савченко.
Можна шукати безліч причин. Судді не хотіли більше відчувати
на собі тиск  від адміністрації, від генпрокурора,
і адвокати спрацювали блискуче.
Натомість для багатьох колег Надії Савченко
її вихід із СІЗО та повернення до Верховної Ради
стали справжньою  несподіванкою.
- Скоріш за все це було
одним із брудних рішень, одним із багатьох брудних рішень,
яке стосувалося
цих перегонів. І, можливо, тут треба...
Дуже шкода, що ми не дізнаємося цього зараз.
Але дуже хотілося знати, чому в нас суддівська гілка влади,
яка мала б бути незалежною,
піддається певному тиску.
- Ми бачимо спробу повернути "Приватбанк"
колишнім власникам, тут повертається в нас
Надія Савченко в парламент.
Так скоро можно і Віктора Федоровича дочекатися.
- Ми ж знаємо, що Надія Савченко - вона є
людиною пана Медведчука зараз.
Може, це була така домовленість.
Надія Савченко не знає, як довго перебуватиме
на волі. На 7 травня призначене чергове судове
засідання в її справі, на якому можуть обрати новий
запобіжний захід. Та це не заважає Савченко
будувати політичні плани. Депутатка має намір
брати участь у парламентських виборах восени цього року.